o sea era la región comprendida por
cuatro por la raíz cuadrada de 9 x y los
ejes en el primer cuadrante podemos ver
que la región r está en gris justo aquí
la región r es la base de un sólido para
cada valor de la sección transversal del
sólido tomada perpendicular al eje y es
un rectángulo cuya base se encuentra en
r y cuya altura es expresa el volumen
del sólido con una integral definida
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
muy bien hagámoslo juntos en primer
lugar tratemos de visualizar el sólido y
trataré de hacerlo dibujando en
perspectiva así que este es nuestro eje
y
y justo aquí tenemos nuestro eje x y
puedo dibujar la región r que es algo
así
ahora imaginemos una sección transversal
de nuestro sólido entonces dice la
sección transversal del sólido tomada
perpendicular al eje y así que vamos a
elegir un valor de aquí vamos a ir
perpendicular al eje y y dice cuya base
se encuentra en r así que la base se
vería así en realidad este sería el
valor de x que corresponde a este valor
particular de y de modo que escribiré x
justo aquí y luego la altura es la
altura va a ser igual a lo que sea
nuestro valor de y luego si quisiéramos
calcular el volumen de una porción que
tiene una profundidad infinitesimal
podríamos pensar en esa profundidad
infinitesimal en términos de i por lo
que podríamos decir que la profundidad
justo aquí es de g
podríamos dibujar otras secciones
transversales por ejemplo justo aquí
nuestro valor de ye es mucho menor
nuestra altura podría verse así
pero luego nuestra base es el valor
correspondiente de x que queda justo en
la curva el par xy que queda en la curva
entonces esta sección transversal se
vería como algo así y una vez más si
queremos calcular el volumen podríamos
decir que es un volumen infinitesimal y
tendría una profundidad de que como
hemos aprendido muchas veces en
integración lo que queremos hacer es
pensar en el volumen de una de estas
rebanadas
supongo que podemos decir así y luego
integrar todas ellas ahora hay un par de
maneras de hacerlo podrías intentar
integrar con respecto a x o podrías
integrar con respecto a y voy a decir
que es mucho más fácil integrar aquí con
respecto a iu porque ya tenemos algo en
términos de de y el volumen de esta
pequeña rebanada será que por x por d y
así que si queremos integrar con
respecto a ella queremos tener todo en
términos de i
expresamos x en términos de y de modo
que aquí tenemos que resolver para x una
manera de hacerlo déjeme ver es dividir
ambos lados entre 4 y obtiene 7 sobre 4
es igual a raíz cuadrada de 9 - x ahora
podemos elevar al cuadrado los dos lados
que cuadrada sobre 16 es igual a 9
x y luego podríamos multiplicar los dos
lados por menos uno menos ya cuadrada
sobre 16 es igual a x menos nueve
podríamos sumar nueve a los dos lados
por lo que obtenemos nueve menos de
cuadradas sobre 16 es igual a equis y
podríamos sustituir esto justo aquí otra
manera de expresar el volumen de esta
pequeña rebanada de profundidad
infinitesimal que tenemos aquí
profundidad de que va a ser igual ayer
por 9 - y cuadradas sobre 16 por d ye y
si queremos encontrar el volumen de la
figura entera
se ve así
sólo tenemos que integrar desde 0 hasta
12 integrar desde cero hasta igual a 12
es todo lo que nos piden hacer expresar
el volumen como una integral definida y
en realidad es una integral definida que
puedes resolver sin calculadora si
multiplicas estos dos términos porque
bueno vas a obtener un polinomio en
términos de iu y sabemos cómo tomar la
anti derivada de eso y luego evaluar una
integral definida hasta el próximo vídeo